Perché sei così felice Dai dimmi perché
sei così felice Sta per arrivare Babbo
Natale non so se vi ricordate sto video
Ma buonasera incredibile papà Federic
sta tornando in questo momento salendo a
casa mia perché mi ha detto sono
arrivate non ti dico niente vengo a casa
tua registriamo e basta quindi da questa
premessa Boh non so più niente Adesso
sta per arrivare federick io non so
niente di quello che sta succedendo
pigliamoci di Papa Federic sta per
suonare in tre due uno
sarebbe stato Fico
Ci siamo Io amo quest'uomo Allora
ragazzi attrezzi del mestiere e si
descatola la Federic box Ecco questo
potrebbe essere la strategia giusta
c'è una scatola del frederix Store
dentro la scatola del Verde È
divertentissimo Ma attenzione perché qua
c'è una scatola del Federic Store però
qua ci sono altre cose la mia amica
Marta Station Sì ti ha regalato queste
qua sono delle cover per le carte che
forse Dopo vedrai Io spero non ci voglio
credere è che non lo fai spacchettare
Favij eh eh sono le figurine Sì allora
abbiamo il pacchetto tra i trick or
Trade e free edition game Cards sentiamo
il peso
è bilanciato perfettamente 2 3 e 4
perché la olo la devi confondere la devi
confondere e adesso abbiamo Innanzitutto
la prima carta
che è un ampere un Hunter con un sacco
di voglia di vivere più della mia e
abbiamo la non comune che è lì che
invece è comune Litwick e poi abbiamo
l'ultima carta che attenzione Oddio
incredibile Grazie grazie mille con un
Pikachu pazzesco valore
[Musica]
e ora te la puoi girare come meglio
credi
Eh
No beh gli hanno dato nove
io non gli avrei dato nemmeno otto
l'ultima volta gli han dato un 9 e
questo che cosa vuol dire la carta era
più perfetta di quanto credevamo ha
anche dei 9.5 non è per niente male
soprattutto perché condizioni della
carta apparentemente non erano così
capito lei comunque toccata più volte
fatte vede' mutande che culo e almeno
triplicato il valore di quando Ok
fighissimo la prossima è una bella bomba
quindi
è già diversa è già diversa da quella di
prima Oddio
centerim 10 corner 10 Borghi 10 Surface
9.55
[Musica]
un pristiin secondo me siamo intorno ai
1500 qualcosa di più anche qualcosa di
più
Porca [ __ ] io in realtà vorrei fare una
cosa
Siccome c'è tanta ignoranza in giro sul
valore di carte delle carte di Pokémon
me compreso vorrei provare a vedere se
la gente effettivamente sa di cosa
stiamo parlando e oggi offrirò le carte
in giro la gente in cambio di oggetti
vediamo se accettano sennò viene da dire
cazzo loro te lo dico tutto sto
pranzetto Mamma mia sei goduto adesso si
paga
con la carta pago con la carta
è bellissimo scambisti solo lo zaino
senza quello che c'è dentro per questa
carta i Pokémon ragazzi
no no no ti ringrazio
Grazie mille
va bene così Ale è figlio unire dei me
contro te che famiglia reale quella là
si vedono da tre o quattro Posso
chiederle una cortesia però posso pagare
con la carta perché non hai contanti
No non c'è il posto più o meno questo
la carta non si tocca detto che non
prende la carta sennò prendevo quella
Però peccato perché familiare era buono
quel Cappelletto è bellissimo lo vuoi
scambiare per una carta di Pokémon